quatre ans de prison dont 18 mois avec
sursis c'est à cette peine que les neuf
vénézuéliens ont été condamnés au
tribunal correctionnel pour trafic
d'herbe de cannabis
au total 43 kg ont été récupérés le 9
février dernier il avait été intercepté
par la marine nationale au large de sète
lucie des vénézuéliens qui ont déclaré
qu'ils avaient tenté cette aventure à
cause de la situation économique de leur
pays
pour les avocats c'est quelque part le
procès de la misère qui s'est déroulée
je crois que ce procès et symbolise la
misère qu'on a dans le monde entier en
ce moment où envoyer les pour le match
par tous mais particulièrement au
venezuela où on voit que le pays est
coupé en deux et celle ci bain dans la
difficulté de tous les jours mais le
marchand de mort d'une misère peuvent
facilement les recruter et compte tenu
des difficultés mais qu'est ce qu'ils
font ben ils vont ils pas les riches
comme a dit ma consoeur est considérée
et puis ils se retrouvent là sont des
gens qui viennent du venezuela ils
viennent parce que ils ont des
difficultés à nourrir leurs familles et
que une des seules possibilités qui
s'offrent à eux
ceux qui sentent le mieux ils prennent
des risques et qu'est ce qu'ils font ils
montent sur des bateaux pour gagner un
petit peu pour pouvoir se payer un peu
de un peu de nourriture pour leurs
familles et donc ils prennent des
risques et on en est là aujourd'hui
les neuf accusés ont entre 24 et 55 ans
ils avaient tous au casier judiciaire
vierge avant les faits ils ont été
conduits directement à la prison de
ducos